so what do we have here we have a
triangle and we know that the length of
ac is equal to the length of cb so this
is an isosceles triangle we have two of
its legs are equal to each other and
then they also tell us that this line up
here they didn't put another label there
let me put another label there just for
fun let's call this this you could even
call this array because it's starting at
c that line or ray cd is parallel to
this segment a b over here and that's
interesting then they give us they give
us these two angles right over here
these adjacent angles they give it to us
in terms of x and what i want to do in
this video is try to figure out what x
is
and so given that they told us that this
angle that this line and this line are
parallel and you could we can turn this
into line cd so it's not just array
anymore so it just keeps going on and on
in both directions
the fact they've given us a parallel
line tells us that maybe we can use some
of what we know about transversals and
parallel lines to figure out some of the
angles here and you might recognize
you might recognize that this right over
here this line let me do that in a
better color
you might recognize that line cb is a
transversal
for those two parallel lines
let's let me draw both of the parallel
lines a little bit
more so that you can recognize that as a
transversal and then a few things might
jump out you have this x plus 10 right
over here and its corresponding angle is
right down here this would also be x
plus 10 and if this is x plus 10 then
you have a vertical angle right over
here that would also be x plus 10 or you
could say that you have alternate
interior angles that would also be
congruent either way this base angle is
going to be x plus 10. well it's an
isosceles triangle so your two base
angles are going to be congruent so if
this is x plus 10 then this is going to
be x plus 10 as well and now we have the
three angles of a triangle expressed as
as functions of expressed in terms of x
so when we take their sum they need to
be equal to 180 and then we can actually
solve for x we get 2x
2x
plus
x plus 10
plus x plus 10 plus x plus 10
plus x plus 10 is going to be equal to
180 degrees and then we can add up the
x's so we have a 2x there plus an x plus
another x that gives us 4x
4 x's and then we have a plus 10 and
another plus 10 so that gives us a plus
20 is equal to 180
and we can subtract 20 from both sides
of that and we get 4x
4x is equal to
160 divide both sides by 4 and we get x
is equal to 40 and we're done we figured
out what x is and then we can actually
figure out what these angles are if this
is x plus 10 then you have 40 plus 10
this right over here is going to be a 50
degree angle this is 2x so 2 times 40
this is an 80 degree angle it doesn't
look at the way i've drawn it and that's
why you should never take anything you
should never assume anything based on
how a diagram is drawn so this right
over here is going to be an 80 degree
angle and that these two base angles
right over here are also going to be are
also going to be 50 degrees so you have
50 degrees 50 degrees and 80 they add up
to 180 degrees